[Music]
far across the sea
an island calls
the thing ever stays nice
it always turns bad
things aren't always nice you can change
them
no
the way we always do
we fight
how far will you go to save the ones you
love
a plague tale requiem picks up a few
months after the end of innocence
right around the first days of summer
amesia and hugo are headed south along
with their mother beatrice and the young
alchemist lucas
reaching places still spared by the
devouring plague the raging wars and the
rabid rats that are running rampant in
the north
is that affair
beneath the warm sun of 14th century
provence
the darunes are almost able to enjoy a
normal life
but for a recurrent dream that hugo has
been having of a mysterious island that
calls him
how come nobody noticed that
disappearance maybe nobody cares
maybe
one day the macular illness that's been
dormant inside hugo awakens
and the dreaded living nightmare begins
again
in the wake emacia finds herself with no
other choice but to trust her brother's
dreams and head further south towards
the elusive island
before he's consumed by the terrible
macular affliction the bite yes
they brought the arena down they let
them die here
starting all over again
her mind is made up
she will find a cure in what dreams and
prophecy may hold get used to it with
almost no one they can trust this is
your life now emicia and hugo must
traverse land and water as restless
forces stand against them
after the events of last winter
emisia is hardened
experienced and when backed against the
wall can be surprisingly resourceful
with several new tricks up her sleeve
she is now able to freely choose between
striking from the shadows or unleashing
hell with a variety of equipment and
tools
hugo wants more than ever to help his
big sister and not hinder their progress
we need to leave or we'll do everything
the macula within him is a double-edged
sword that has deepened his connection
with the rats
they can feel people's blood now i can
too
this powerful ability can decimate
entire squads of soldiers
but takes a severe toll on hugo every
time he uses it what's wrong
what's wrong
thankfully their journey brings not only
hardship but also unexpected friends
these colorful characters help the
darunes carry their terrible burden it's
not my first time while offering unique
skills and resources to bring them
closer to their elusive goat
as soon as he's gone
for amesia and hugo the road ahead will
test the limits of what they can endure
on all levels
and just how far they're willing to go
reaching the island is only the first
step to truly understanding the terrible
affliction that stricken their family as
the lines between reality
fantasy and fate dissolve
keeping it together and finding the cure
to save hugo
will be nothing short of a miracle
but emesia has hope
and hope is the last thing lost
others are burned in it
if you kill be ready to beat it
[Music]
a plaguetail requiem releases october
18th on playstation 5 xbox series pc and
nintendo switch